we have one more question go ahead I
heard Bobby on fight under the kid and I
was glad to find out he had a podcast I
have a problem for you I have a question
for you I always have had a sexual
problem ever since the first time I had
sex I last too long and I rarely orgasm
I'm passing sex when I was younger it
wasn't a problem because of course it's
not the worst problem to have but over
time in relationships it has become one
what does comes to long no he doesn't
orgasm he doesn't yeah is he having sex
with who's having sex with men or women
I am whichever one it is you should do
the other one mm-hmm
I can masturbate normally and I don't
masturbate a lot
just a couple times a week I do watch
porn but again not all the time when it
comes to sex I just seemed to last too
long and never just enjoy a quickie do
you think it's just in my head
no I think that I think neither are
girls enormous vagina is not a lot of
people they aren't just sexual be yeah
there's not an interaction with another
person who doesn't have to do with his
desire to have sex this guy is obviously
very sexually active
it's his least there's something
desensitize probably in his penis
because I dated a boy in high school and
it was so annoying how he just took too
long I don't like them to last more than
seven minutes so what he's saying you
know gives me he's the rudest
[ __ ] ever to me all the time and
now you see this don't believe none of
this [ __ ] this is a tremendous actor
right here wait you see the new ABC show
would you say about like first that was
a compliment what because you saw the
trailer of my ABC show yeah no I don't
know is I think no no no is a complete
compliment when I saw the scene where
you're in the street have you seen it
he's telling it I was like I don't even
know who the [ __ ] that was because
that's so not him so that shows you have
some acting right yeah but no but that's
not that they write it no no no no Bobby
Bobby right you have to if it was they
wrote I know but not everybody can do
that you made some choices I believed
you
like I don't believe you now in real
life you know what I mean and I believed
and I believed that so I'm not making
fun huh Eric answer this guy's question
what should he do about his I think he
should experiment I mean is he doing the
same thing every time they change it up
mix it up you know mix it up you should
try different things you know what I'm
saying that bring some toys in or [ __ ]
ring yeah no not a Cochran that's gonna
make it he's gonna let he's already last
[ __ ] ring different experiment and like
I said if you try man he's gonna grow
yeah you try that